good morning Hank it's Tuesday so every
year at VidCon I try to make pretty good
choices until Saturday evening when I
traditionally celebrate the end of
VidCon by participating in a youtube
show called beer and board games this
year there was a significant emphasis on
the beer part of beer and board games so
full disclosure I'm a little bit hazy on
the details of how this all went down
semi-related story I lost my video
camera so I have no VidCon footage which
is also why we're stuck with the old
camera this week but right so after beer
and board games I ran into minutephysics
Henry and smartereveryday Destin and CGP
grey gray and somehow we got to talking
about Iceland hey I am a huge fan of
Iceland it just contains so many things
I love hot baths and improbably
excellent football team Bjork
etc there's really just the one problem
with Iceland which you know is that it's
located in Iceland like Sarah and I
visited Iceland in August of 2008 and we
went on this bus tour and our tour guide
reading from a script' said without any
irony Iceland may have ice in its name
but as you can see the weather is quite
mild here year round
perhaps we should switch names with
Greenland haha and then we got off the
bus and that August afternoon it was
perhaps half a degree above freezing and
because of the howling winds the rain
was of course raining appeared to be
coming up from the ground which for the
record was not green it was brown on
account of it being recently dried lava
so okay the four of us discussed problem
1 the Iceland being an Iceland problem
for a little bit and then we pivoted to
a seemingly unrelated problem which is
that currently there is no convenient
midway point on the Atlantic side
between the Americas and afro-eurasia
like on the Pacific side you have Hawaii
or if you're feeling adventurous the
Cook Islands but on the Atlantic side
pretty much nothing until that is we
relocate Iceland our proposal Hank is to
move Iceland from here where it is
constantly raining and spewing lava to
say here where it would be a lovely
stopping point between continents quick
sidenote I honestly think if we'd had a
better located Iceland in the first
place humans probably would have had
earlier and more robust trade between
the Americas and afro-eurasia which in
turn might have mitigated some of the
horrors of the Columbian Exchange both
on a human and a biodiversity level so
you know not to criticize plate
tectonics or anything but I think this
could
and handled better from the beginning
that said the world is what it is or at
least it was until we learn to build
Islands right so we formed a coalition
to create new Iceland a nation with one
great weather - Bjork and three
apparently a better soccer team than
England has plus four it's only a
two-hour flight from New York Madrid or
Marrakesh Destin assigned Henry with the
job of actually moving Iceland which you
know I'm not a scientist but it can't be
that hard I figure we just get a big
tugboat or something and pull it south
CGP Grey was given the job of designing
a flag for new Iceland destin assigned
himself something having to do with
rockets and i was tasked with the
political problem of getting the people
of Iceland to agree to move their
country you know about 3,000 miles
south-southwest of its current location
so here we go people of Iceland hello
you may have noticed that your nation is
very cold and rainy in the winter and
then very cold and rainy in the summer
also remember in January when the Sun
rose at noon or or rather would have
risen if it weren't perpetually overcast
I'd like to solve those problems and
give you beaches warmth sunshine and joy
all while allowing you to keep your
Bjork so what do you say Iceland I
imagine you're gonna say know that you
like your country where it is despite
its geographical shortcomings maybe that
says something about Iceland ders or
maybe it says something about change
that dangerous and beautiful force that
drives and defines the universe still
I'm hoping you'll say yes because I
could really use a vacation in sunny new
Iceland Hank
congratulations on a great VidCon I'll
see you on Friday